- [Cameraman] 20,000 people? (laughs)
- All right, calm it down D-Rock, Jesus.
(dramatic music)
(cheering)
- You got your perspective.
(applauding)
I just want to be happy.
Don't you want to be happy?
Here's how I think we should do it.
I think you guys should
be sending me clips,
and if you don't get an answer,
I think you do it twice,
like what you just did,
and I think tonight you go with
the third and final chance,
otherwise we're gonna title
five, is the right way to do it.
- Perfect.
- Got it?
(mumbling in background)
- Yeah, I thought so too, okay.
♪ And sometimes, stay inside, of my mind ♪
♪ I gotta get out, I gotta decide ♪
- I just don't think
people externally realize
the machine that Vayner is.
- [Gary] Definitely not.
- It's incredible.
Yeah, it's really incredible.
I'm seriously blown away by it.
- Yeah I mean, when you
purposefully disguise something,
it's hard for anybody to know.
- [Harriet] Yeah.
♪ Hey hey hey ♪
♪ Keep gettin' in my own way ♪
♪ Overthinking, I think
I'm insane, I'm crazy ♪
- I couldn't believe more
that going from two to 50,
is like, going from 50 to 100 is easier,
the problem is people go from two to 50,
and then they change everything
'cause they think they've made
it, or they figured it out,
or they go from humility to
ego, their behavior changes.
And the reason 50 to 100
is equally as hard, is that
it becomes a mental game
based on the predicated
success of the past.
And I think staying in
those tried-and-true,
being this proportionally bringing value
to the end consumer,
hiring the right people.
What I get excited about
when I hear you talk is
understanding that how
to go all in, and how to
be great at LinkedIn marketing,
not just do it, right.
You know, I always think about that.
I think about like, a kid who has an uncle
who comes and visits,
and then all of a sudden
puts them on skis and they love it.
And they're like, oh, this is good,
but then they have to put in the work.
And that's why they
become an Olympic skier.
It did take the uncle to show them.
But then it took them to put
in the work and the practice
to get the ridiculous results from it.
- [Casey] Hey, it's D-Rock,
D-Rock, how are you?
- Harriet, pleasure to meet you.
- Harriet just joined
Vayner to lead all comms
for the VaynerX world.
Zach is the CO of VaynerSpeakers.
Tea situation is proper!
(laughing)
- [Man] Did you ask for tea?
- No but it is super proper tea!
- [Man] As if there's one
thing you'd want them to do.
- As a nice Russian Jewish
boy, tea is like culture.
- [Harriet] I'm a massive tea drinker.
- Of course, that's like the one thing
me and all my UK friends like,
when I first started
going to London a bunch,
that was the one thing
that I like resonated with.
So this is gorgeous.
I don't want to know the questions.
- Yeah I was supposed to say,
I'm not going over these
with Gary, no fucking way.
(laughs)
- Yeah I don't want to know them.
- [Woman] Oh, well then that's fine.
- I feel like we should
go live on Instagram.
I literally have a phone
'cause I think we should
call people and just make their day.
We have all this time, I'm
like literally stressed
by having this much time before we go on.
We should call people randomly.
That's literally what I'm thinking.
But you do what you need to do.
(laughing)
(chilled music)
Well there's just too much downtime.
So I was going to make content!
Get a good, are you ready?
So many people are like asking me, how?
How do I live my dream, Gary?
And you know, I don't have
time, I have mortgages,
and bills and
responsibilities, and my job.
I don't have time for my side
hustle, my Twitch channel,
my Instagram account, my
Shopify store selling hoodies.
And I keep getting to
this new place which is,
talk to me about your bills.
Why'd you buy an apartment
that stretches you?
Why is your car so fancy?
Why do you need the new Gucci every time?
Why are you going out Thursday,
Friday and Saturday night?
Why are you going to Coachella?
Why are you going to
Avengers opening night
and buying the biggest
piece of popcorn and candy?
The answer to all of your questions
is not how much money you make
or how much time you have,
it's what you're spending your money on.
- [Cameraman] Yeah.
- We could do a lot more of this.
This is what we used to do.
That's like a good piece of content.
There might not be anything
more human than Tinder,
yet we demonize it in reverse.
'Cause it is not the current
socially-accepted thing.
I really believe that.
I think when people judge people,
I'm like, what are you supposed to do
with your chemicals, in your 20s?
That's exactly, the
most actual true human,
you know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- We've evolved so much that
this is how we look at it.
But you know what?
It's on your time to control
when you're engaging,
versus I'm going to set aside three hours,
and go to the bar, in 1987
and see what happens,
versus the collective.
The three-and-a-half week
ghosting conversation
is still 1/10 of the amount of time
that going out on that
Friday, you know what I mean?
You're in control of your time!
You're in between subway
stops, and now you decided
to hit up that conversation, I don't know.
Look, technology exposes things,
it doesn't change things,
and so, I don't know.
I sit on the other side, I guess.
- Well on that note.
- Yes.
That online dating is
the greatest thing that's
ever happened to people.
And they're in control of it.
You don't like it, don't use it.
I love people that demonize online dating,
but then shit on people
writing letters, right.
Like, pick a side.
- [Man] Yeah.
♪ This far, this far ♪
♪ I'ma make it happen, keep working hard ♪
♪ Sometimes stay inside of my mind ♪
♪ Gotta get out, I gotta decide ♪
♪ Every little thing will be all right ♪
♪ Yeah sometimes stay inside of my mind ♪
♪ I gotta get out, I gotta decide ♪
♪ Every little thing will be all right ♪
♪ Yeah sometimes I stay
inside of my mind ♪
♪ I got get out ♪
- This is it, I'm super excited about it.
- [Cameraman] Fire it up.
- Uh-huh.
Super, super excited about it.
Once it gets like, two to 3,000
you can tell them what I'm about to do.
All right, so I'm tasting this
and then we're going into a meeting?
- Yeah.
- So I might as well
bang this out real quick, okay good.
- [Cameraman] There are 2800 people in.
- Awesome.
- [Cameraman] 20,000 people! (laughs)
- All right, calm it down D-Rock, Jesus.
D-Rock's excited.
Instagram, big news.
This is the first time
I'm trying the Empathy Wines white.
Which will start delivering in?
- [Nate] We're bottling starting Thursday.
- This is Nate, the handsome partner.
Trout. (laughs)
You were supposed to say
the brains or something.
- We're starting to bottle Thursday,
then it's going to be shipped
to our fulfillment center.
Needs a little bit of time to rest.
Build the boxes.
- No bottle shock!
- No bottle shock.
We should be shipping third
or fourth week of May.
So, three-to-four weeks.
- Well, do you think, somebody might
sneak it for Memorial Day?
- Near California, I think could sneak.
- That's cool.
- Fulfillment center's in--
- But right, without over-promising,
4th of July is gonna be lit.
- 100%.
Early June, 100%.
- By the way, if you're
not reordering your rose,
you're making a huge mistake.
You can order rose in three, six,
three, six, 12s by itself right now
if you go to Empathy Wines.
I know a bunch of you have
gone through your rosé already.
So go do that.
If you order three, it's 27 bucks,
if you order a case it's 20 bucks.
Something we need to
communicate to some peeps.
All right, here it is!
Just warming it up a little bit more.
- [Trout] Yeah, the amount
of reorder is crazy.
Just goes to show how good the wine is.
A lot of people are.
- Yeah, no I know, like, thank god!
(laughs)
But that is the one
difference between the book
and the sneakers, and the
wine, is the reordering.
First of all, a lot of
people didn't believe
it was going to be good, so everybody,
they got their three rosés,
and the amount of people
that hit me up that said,
I bought it to support you,
I was going to give it away.
And then me or my wife, or my husband,
or whoever, we tried it, and we like it,
and now we just ordered it, so.
- [Nate] You know,
that's a great placement.
- [Trout] Really?
- You focus on wine, and you let D-Rock
focus on content, and
it's a good situation.
You fucked it up, didn't you Rock?
You were trying to do double, got it.
Here we go, the white,
aromatics are killer.
We're gonna win that game.
What's the final breakdown of varietals?
Do you know?
- I just got the tech sheet.
- That means you do know.
- Chenin blanc.
- What up!
- [Trout] Chardonnay, Grenache blanc.
- Ooh, so, Chenin and Grenache blanc
are two of the three
most highest percentages?
- Yep.
- How much chenin?
- 27%.
- Love it, love it!
Guys, I made this wine,
we made this wine with,
actually, I can't say we,
'cause I can't speak to what
these guys were thinking,
but for me selfishly when
we were tasting, I was like,
yo, we need to make out a wine
that just changes the white wine game,
'cause rosé and red
are eating up the game.
Red has been established,
rosé is eating into white.
We gotta get people
excited about white again.
And I don't think that can
just be Sauvingon blanc,
I don't think that just can be Chardonnay,
I think it needs to be a blend.
And when I think of grenache,
and I think of Chenin blanc,
but I think of chardonnay
foundational in the middle,
I'm excited.
All right, what else?
- A little bit of Albarino?
Just a splash of Rodeo and Muscat.
It's a kitchen sink blend, but, all
really exciting grapes.
- Here we go.
Aromatics are litty.
(rap music)
♪ It'll be all right ♪